This episode is sponsored by Wren, a website
where you calculate your carbon emissions.
You can also sign up to make a monthly contribution
to offset your emissions or support rainforest
protection projects by clicking our link in
the description.
In our episode last week, we introduced you
to a particular type of relationship between
two creatures called epibiosis, which is when
one organism takes up residence
on the surface of another.
And we asked which one you would prefer to be,
the one living on, or the one being lived upon.
And there are plenty of pros and cons to either
lifestyle, but these interactions can vary
a lot based on the species involved. So we
promised to dive a little deeper into one
specific example of epibiosis where it might
be a little bit easier to decide because choosing
wrong means death.
This is kentrophoros, a ciliate that James—our
master of microscopes—had been searching
for, receiving samples from all over the world
in the hopes of finding it gliding around.
And finally, it turned up in some sand samples
he received from the Adriatic coast of Italy.
When you first look at it, this kentrophoros
probably doesn’t seem particularly special.
It’s just slowly gliding around the slide,
looking a bit more like a worm than a fascinating
case study in epibiosis.
But there are two things that the kentrophoros
is famous for.
The first is its lack of a mouth.
And the second is its coat of bacteria.
As we zoom in, you can see those bacteria
poking out on one side of the ciliate’s body.
Scientists have actually estimated that one
Kentrophoros can have around 4,500 individual
bacteria living on it.
At least 15 kentrophoros species have been
described, but they can look very different
from one another.
Some are like ours—flat and ribbon-like.
Others are built more like a tube.
Some have their bacterial coat laid out on
one side of their body, while others tuck
the bacteria into pockets made out of their
own self .
The fact that these different species look
so different from one another—and that the
only things really tying them together were
mouthlessness and bacterial companions—meant
that scientists had to ask the question: are
these different species actually related?
It wouldn’t be the first, or last, time
that we’d been led astray
by a few coincidental similarities.
But when they studied the Kentrophoros’
DNA, they found that the species are in
fact related to each other, suggesting that
they may have evolved this relationship with
their bacterial friends long ago and spread
the partnership all over the world.
When you look at the bacteria on their own,
you can see their rod shape more clearly.
These bacteria are primarily thiotrophs, meaning
that they live on sulfur.
When researchers dug into the genetics of
these bacteria, they found that they were
all members of the same clade, Gammaproteobacteria—a
type of bacteria that includes more famous
sulfur bacteria like Beggiatoa.
But additional work found evidence of another
type of bacteria in that coat as well called
Muribaculaceae—a branch of bacteria that
includes residents of our own guts.
Now we mentioned earlier that James found these
Kentrophoros in samples that came from the
Adriatic Coast, and that’s no accident.
Kentrophoros are usually found in marine sediments,
and that is thanks in part to the thiotrophic
bacteria that live on their surface.
Their relationship reminds us a bit of Paramecium
bursaria and the green algae Chlorella that
live as endosymbionts inside of vacuoles specially
designed to hold them.
Chlorella love sun, using it to drive their
photosynthesis so they can make their own food.
And so, to suit the needs of their internal
residents, Paramecium bursaria are also drawn
to well-lit areas.
It is an exchange that works very well for
both the algae and the paramecium.
The algae gets the safety of the paramecium’s
body, and the paramecium gets some of the
nutritional benefit of whatever the algae
has made.
The Kentrophoros’ relationship with their
thiotrophic bacteria is similar, except that
the bacteria live on the Kentrophoros instead
of inside them.
And instead of being drawn to light, the Kentrophoros
are drawn instead to that band of water that
hovers above the sediment where oxygen is
low and there is just enough hydrogen sulfide
for their bacteria to convert into food.
By letting themself be drawn to these areas,
the Kentrophoros benefits as well, taking
in some of the metabolites made by the bacteria.
And it seems that this exchange has paid off
enough for both the bacteria and the Kentrophoros.
The kentrophoros’ cilia is distributed in
a way to make sure that there are specific
places kept free and clear for their surface
tenants.
And the pockets we described some kentrophoros
species as having maximize the amount of space
available for the bacteria to attach themselves
too.
Meanwhile, the kentrophoros’ bacteria divide
in a way that is not typically seen, but
that makes sense when you remember how it
lives.
Typically, a rod-shaped bacteria would divide
down the middle, along its shorter axis.
But these bacteria tear apart down the longer
axis, breaking apart into a sort of “V”
shape that then splits into two.
And why would it do that?
Because it lets them stay attached to their
host as they divide, hooked on through the
root of that “V” until it’s ready to
completely separate into two.
And this all seems to be fairly balanced,
well-managed relationship of the microcosmos.
The bacteria gets access to sulfur, the Kentrophoros
gets access to nutrients.
What could possibly go wrong?
Well, a lot, if you are the bacteria.
Because sometimes, the Kentrophoros gets hungry…
too hungry.
A few metabolites from their bacterial buddies
just aren’t enough anymore.
But the bacteria themselves?
Well, that is a handy snack to have on hand.
The kentrophoros may be mouthless, but it
is not harmless.
It has a trick up its sleeve: phagocytosis.
It simply absorbs the bacteria into itself
and begins to eat.
In some descriptions of the relationship between
Kentrophoros and bacteria, the scientists
Bland Finlay and Tom Fenchel have used the
phrase “kitchen garden” to describe them,
which is a quaint image from the Kentrophoros’
point of view.
It's kinda sweet, after all, to imagine the ciliate
raising a field of bacteria, fertilizing it
with trips through anoxic waters and tending
to its needs.
But from the bacteria’s point of view, it
must feel like a bit of a betrayal.
Like the whole ground beneath their feet has
just opened up and swallowed them whole.
And in our imagination, that seems like the
far worse place to exist.
If you were to ask the simple question of
“who would you rather be,” the answer
feels to us like an easy one.
It seems much more appealing to be the creature
who chooses to consume the other, not the
one who goes from friend to phagocytosed without
warning.
But maybe we are being
too human about this.
The relationship between these bacteria and
the ciliate has gone on for a long time, covering
oceans on opposite sides of the planet.
There is something about this that must work
for the bacteria, even if we don’t have
the capacity to imagine it working for us.
Perhaps there is something to this life—attached
to the side of another creature’s body,
surviving as countless copies of yourself
endure—perhaps there’s something to all
that makes sense when it’s all you’ve
known.
And perhaps it is our life…our way of imagining
ourselves as whole, complete individuals rather
than as a single note in the broader symphony
of our species that is truly bizarre.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Wren for sponsoring this
episode.
Wren is a website where you can calculate
your carbon emissions, then offset it by funding
projects like ones that help improve the transparency
and scientific integrity of carbon removal
and climate solutions through open data, tools,
and leadership.
We will need a lot of different approaches
to stop the climate crisis, and this is one
way that you can learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action.
You’ll answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and they’ll also show you ways
you can start reducing your carbon emissions.
Now no one can reduce their footprint to zero,
yet, but using Wren,
you can help offset what you have left.
Once you sign up, you’ll receive updates
from the tree planting, rainforest protection,
and other projects you support.
And we have partnered with Wren to plant 10
additional trees for the first 100 people
who sign up using the link in our description!
The people on your screen right now, are the
folks who make it possible to scour the world
for the microbes we want to share with the
world.
This is a big beautiful planet, and I think
part of what makes living here worthwhile
is paying a lot of concentrated attention
to it.
And these people, here on the screen I think
they agree.
And if you’d like to become one of them,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneyToMicro,
where we have a bunch of cool perks.
If you wanna see more from our Master of Microscopes,
James Weiss, you can check out Jam & Germs on Instagram,
and if you wanna see more from us, there’s
always  a Subscribe button somewhere nearby.